i run a sales company and
my style of teaching
works with
it used to work only with one type of
personality yeah and i realize i'm
one-dimensional then i want to adjust
because i was only attracting single
guys
that don't have any kids and they're 18
to 25 years old yeah and i said no i'm
selling insurance i got to be able to
adjust and you know relate to the
married man yeah so then that that it
opened up and it was three different
ways of communicating with three
different audiences then it goes five
seven so now you become
multi-dimensional absolutely
did your dad's messaging resonate with
your sister because your sister is a
lawyer she also is successful how did
she receive his messaging yeah my sister
is very successful she is a lawyer and i
do think it resonated to a degree
however i think my father's world view
was so primal
and so based in
many things which have a masculine edge
like
threats and violence and enemies and
things that women don't truly consider
that i think his teaching style was far
more akin to to men and even i i think
that's just how he was i think that it's
easy for a man to adopt it i don't think
that many women and i don't become able
to misogynist this is just my world view
i don't think many women have a true
because it's not their job to be to some
degree they feel like managed to protect
them to some degree most of them i don't
feel like they have a true akin to
threats sometimes i
i give a million different examples but
if i go on a date with a girl in a
restaurant
the first thing she wants to do is put
on instagram instantly oh like no no
whoa whoa you can't we're here now like
you can't be putting that we're on in
this restaurant with the napkin and the
late that's how they kill pop smoke like
calm down
but it doesn't consider their mind as a
threat or that many women don't accept
that there are groups of men right now
sitting in rooms scrolling social media
looking for someone to get
looking for someone to get they're just
sitting 10 ten brothers
from [ __ ] knows where sitting there just
going hmm ah
that was ten minutes ago this tag oh mr
brigay yeah tate's in miami
it's real
this doesn't really cross female
consciousness sometimes and i understand
why because i think if a woman knew how
dangerous the world is she wouldn't
leave the house so it's easier just to
not look at that world but um the way my
dad taught and the things she said it
resonated with me my brother morton
would resonate with my sister my
sister's still very very successful in
her own way and she's married now and
she's a kid et cetera and she has her
own man et cetera but also i think when
a woman gets married she takes influence
from the man she marries
lots of different things but my my
biggest male influence was my father
always will be there'll be no one else
your sister should take the influence
from her husband that's the man she
wants to be and she wants her son to
replicate
the man she's had a kid with then yeah
she absolutely should take his influence
i completely respect that and understand
it but my biggest male influence in my
life will always be my father can never
be replicated or replaced whereas hers
possibly could tristan's your best
friend brother business partner the
whole thing everything what would you
describe your sister as
much as your sister yeah my sister's my
sister yeah and i wish her the absolute
best i have nothing bad to say about her
i wish her the absolute best but
the bond me and my brother have i don't
want to say this in any kind of negative
way i don't feel like i couldn't live
with my sister full-time
like in a same house talking about like
it just wouldn't be it'd be weird i
don't know why i always think there's
gonna be some degree of disconnect just
because of the gender if someone hurt
her i'd be the first person to be there
and help her of course but she belongs
to her man now they're married they're
happy they're in love they have a child
and and she has a degree a separate life
because me and my brother's lives will
always be interconnected to the end how
do you get along with her husband he's a
good guy yeah he's a really nice guy he
has nothing bad to say about me funnily
enough
doesn't want smoke
he's all right he's alright if you
enjoyed this video and you want to watch
the entire podcast click over here and
if you want to be connected with experts
influencers such as kiyosaki tate
connolly parliamentary myself and others
download the app minect where you get a
chance to connect with these folks by
the minute you get to buy the minute or
have face times with them 15 minutes ask
them any questions you may want to have
download the app connect and start
connecting with influencers and experts
today
[Music]